first time that we talked about calling
up hotels
i was like you know when we were we were
hanging out and i was like yeah well
like i didn't expect that you would
check in under your real name
and you said [ __ ] uh
you said no dude i wouldn't check into
hotels under my name
i would check into uh [ __ ]
what was it you said that you had a fake
name that you would check into hotels
with called like
something cox enormous or dixie norman's
oh yeah
dixon yeah or yeah dick's enormous
peter peter goes in yeah
oh my god what a [ __ ] so much fun
dude doing
the alias just coming up the [ __ ] up
names and
i my mom god bless her uh
uh she is really [ __ ] greek i mean
greek
greek and she'd be like and you know i
she i would give her my hotel alias
because she'd call
this is before a [ __ ] cell phone
crazy yeah she'd actually call the hotel
and she'd and every time i would tell
her hey mom i switched my name i'm under
this and she'd be
and she'd be so bummed why don't
why tom tom do we have to do it like
this because i don't like
this peter goes in your stuff
i don't like you know like just like she
would hate it but
and i would do it almost just to make
her [ __ ] crazy she's like oh god
i have to ask for [ __ ] this person
like
i'm just always bummed around i i gotta
ask and we can cut this out but
was she bummed on the sex tape that came
out she
she was like she was [ __ ] really
tripping she was bummed like she was mad
she's like i can't believe
and she understood it was just like a
you know
me and my wife at the time on vacation
doing the same [ __ ] that
y'all would do with your chicks right
wow yeah
she was just like i can't believe
someone stole that
you know out of your house and now it's
on the [ __ ] news
you know that's that's what made
her upset more than anything she just
couldn't believe that
but you're like dude mommy's cool i got
the hugest dong
well this is it's not a bad thing mom
it's cool
i mean dude we actually surveyed a
hundred people
asking them like to name a celebrity
with a huge [ __ ]
and a hundred percent of them
yeah dude that's awesome all one hundred
that's [ __ ] steering the boat
dude
you are the poster child for having
that's [ __ ] crazy
i mean who else is known for having a
big dong uh
what tommy lee
yeah dude